okay so you guys are gonna hate me and
before the audience hates me please
follow me on twitter at jamie hilstein
send him your hate there subscribe to my
podcast uh instagram at the jamie
hillstein isn't that
more evidence for one more police
training and two if you're gonna own a
gun so for me i i want to own a gun now
and i've been anti-gun but i don't want
to own a gun until i know
just like with jiu jitsu just like that
i can proficiently that can be taught
and that i can train every week
especially under stress so isn't that
also
an example of why people
should get training before they get a
firearm and law enforcement actually
maybe needs more training so that even
though tamir rice even though maybe the
toy gun looked more realistic that
you're confident enough to assess the
situation before you just open fire on
who turns out to be a kid everybody
wants to go after law enforcement with
these shootings and how about train the
crook not to point the gun at the law
enforcement horse look at the
knucklehead the other day pulled up next
to the traffic stop right did he have an
axe or something and he went after the
officer now the officer was trying to
back up do the best he could to keep
that separation because it's 21 feet
fellas well that's that's that's the
number but i think we i think we can do
both like this is the argument that
happens i remember even when i was in
super woke wokey mode when i would
advocate for women to
train jiu jitsu
people would go you're victim blaming
it's not their fault they shouldn't have
to do anything you know we need to teach
men how not to rape and it's like well
yes we do
but also
until people stop
training jiu jitsu will help you yeah
i'm i'll finish with this on this yeah
please i i've said it and i'll say it
again and and that is is that
if you comply
if you comply to all the criminals out
there the ones that carry guns they
shouldn't have guns the felons all these
guys are going to go by
if you comply
you will not die
that's it it's very simple if you comply
with you will not die and when you look
at michael brown and all these others i
mean michael brown's fingerprint was on
the officer's weapon so if you're out
there fighting and holding court on the
side of the road this and that there's a
high probability something could go
wrong and it may take you it could cost
you your life so just comply if you
comply criminals you will not die
yeah a lot of these uh circumstances you
see people uh
not not just shootings they just are
arguing with the cops and they don't
understand that whether whether you want
it to be reality or not it is if a cop
is stopping you you will gain nothing by
fighting with him and talking with him
that's the funniest thing it's like
you're being arrested i love it when i
hear these activists at occupy they were
like i have not been read my rights like
and but they watch movies and they think
a cop has to mirandize you because they
watched you throw a brick at somebody
these people don't know what they're
talking about you keep your mouth shut
unfortunately you know there there are
instances where police have wrongly
arrested people during i could buy wall
street i actually filmed the cops
wrongly arrest somebody they lied in the
police report got a different officer to
sign off on it and i filmed it
i i want those officers charged
criminally but that doesn't happen that
to me is the problem the issue isn't
the issue is when an officer is breaking
the law violating their out to the
constitution
but if this is what really frustrates me
too there's a video where there's like a
black dude walking on the street and the
cops are like hey come and talk to us
for a minute stop and he goes no and
they're like you you are being detained
it's time to go no and they fight with
them and they're like i can't believe
the cops did that and it's like dude
cops have a right to stop you to ask you
questions they can they can detain you
for a small amount of time it's it's the
way the thing the system goes you might
not like it i get it
but fighting with cops when they're like
what are you doing in this area is not
going to er is not going to win anything
for you you're not going to win on
activism you're not going to win on the
law all you're going to do is make
everything worse
everyone agrees yeah well it's well it
seems common sensical though right and
people will
so
i've
been thinking about this and this is
something i've
i don't think i've really discussed on
this podcast or oh no actually we did
kind of talk about this the other day
but
it makes sense in a very polarized
environment where people have very
different opinions that we're going to
end up
disagreeing on things at such a
fundamental level that there are certain
issues where we won't be able to reach a
compromise right and so whether you're
talking about abortion or homosexuality
or any of these other issues
when it comes to police shootings
these are not matters of principle these
are case-by-case situations that have to
be investigated right if you hear a
police officer shot someone it's not i'm
for that or i'm against that it's all
right well let's look into it and see
what happened but for whatever reason we
are in a place in this country where
people will hear that a police officer
shot someone and they will immediately
know that he is guilty and not only that
he's guilty but if the person was a
minority that he was guilty and he did
it because that person was a minority
there that is insane there are stories
that i think should be pointed out but
people need to be careful not to
conflate the outliers and the accidents
so there's that one famous moment where
a guy gets pulled over black dude gets
pulled over in a van he gets out of the
v he's like cops has got a vehicle he
gets out and the cop says show me your
id and he goes okay he turns back into
the car and the cop just shoots him the
guy like he was going for something it's
like you two probably you told them to
get the id right you have uh someone
mentioned philando castile are you
familiar with this case
he was a uh legally able to carry a
weapon the cop panicked and shot him
there's another issue of like he
shouldn't have been shot but he was also
smoking smoking pot while he was driving
so that kind of muddied things up but he
shouldn't have been shot there yeah it's
not a death penalty offense they're
they're the issue is
how do we deal with these
accidents and outliers
i think the challenge is we need to
actually have a sit-down conversation we
need to analyze what causes these and
then figure out is there something we
can do to make sure they don't happen
while making sure cops are safe when
they do their jobs
there's no there's not a cop that i've
ever spoken to that agrees with what
derek chavin did uh to george floyd
that they would agree with that and and
he should go to prison but gentlemen
there are hundreds of thousands of stops
made up to millions each and every month
each and every month on traffic stops
and you're going to find law enforcement
officers that that
make judgment calls and they could be
the wrong call you're going to get some
that are going to get scared you talk
about uvaldi now why do those guys not
go into that building i don't know but
but the point is is it's a very very
difficult job and and everybody should
go through what that media person went
through yeah you know we we have police
academy training citizens please get
them it's a fats training and they go
through and they realize it's just not
as easy as it just seems like you just
so the point is is that there's very
very few
officer involved shootings today i mean
come on when you look at the number of
contacts with citizens today very few
result in
police officers firing their weapons and
when they do they're scrutinized before
the damn bullet even hits the
you know it's just crazy i think it's
375 million interactions per year
something like that and out of that
there were i think what was it nine
unarmed black men killed in 2019 and
even that is a little deceptive right
because first of all it's possible to
shoot someone who's armed and for that
to be unjustified but also it's possible
to shoot an unarmed person and for that
to be just justified so when you look
into these unarmed cases one of them
from a couple years ago i was looking at
was he was strangling an old lady and
then went to attack the cop it's just
insane
even if you hear the words unarmed black
man shot by a police officer you don't
know anything about yourself until you
know something about the story you see
that viral video where the guy's coming
at the cop with a knife and he's backing
away for like 30 seconds going no no but
then the guy grabs his part and he goes
no no then he starts shooting the guy
and the guy gets shot and he gets back
up he gets back up that that's he he
gets shot because he's coming at the cop
then after being shot he grabs his
partner and then the cop gets it shoots
him in the head it's it's like
people you know you know what i think
one of the issues is
it's the algorithmic psychosis i call it
let's say you're 10 years old and the
year is 2012
and you open up facebook and the only
thing you're seeing yeah is police
brutality videos
remember remember that song where it's
like this is what you get when you call
the cops it's like the guy rapping right
like it's a really good song but it's
like
facebook recycles those videos
because it gets clicks people make money
so then other people recycle them reddit
was doing the same thing
10 years goes by
where you're you're 10 years old
watching these videos and for 10 years
it's all you see you believe that is the
world oh bro that's what i was telling
you before that's why literally
at 40 years old it's like the first time
i'm talking to
conservatives or
law enforcement or and by the way
the all the law enforcement friends i
have said the exact same thing that you
said about um the george floyd murder
where they were the most horrified and i
think if we got rid of this us versus
them mentality
and then we could let
let the good cops speak up and be like
that shouldn't have happened and then
they go continue to be good cops i think
i think there are issues but i think
with 375 million interactions we're
talking about like a microscopic
fraction of of error and so there's
something else that i refer to as the
scaling problem and i'll put it this way
most of you watch if you watch
consistently you may have heard me say
it
let's say uh um iphone gives out 100
phones to these celebrities and one
percent of those phones break nobody
cares one celebrity comes out he's like
hey my phone broke and they're like oh
that sucks let's say they give it a 100
million phones and one percent break now
online trending one million tweets
broken phone like whoa all these phones
are broken the same same failure rate
so if you have
you know 375 million police interactions
the margin of er
the acceptable margin of error decreases
as time goes on
if you had 100 cops in the united states
and one percent brutalize someone that's
one cop people would be like it was just
one cop who cares i'm waiting for uh you
get 100 million cops and i got a million
police brutality stories people lose
their mind which means you've got to
reduce the margin of error as you scale
up the size that's impossible to do
infinitely and tim it seems like the
answer to this this problem we have with
police brutality
is that we're going to defund them
matter of fact not to fund them we're
just going to completely abolish them
but i think a majority a solid majority
of the american people support the men
and women
in blue it's that small group that's out
there just raising cane and just causing
problems well i can actually oh no i was
gonna say i can speak as someone who
you know
during the emotion of
everything that happened with george
floyd
i was listening to a lot of that defund
the police people
until i moved to texas and i started
talking to more police and police were
saying hey dude we don't like what
happened either
we actually if you defund us that's less
training right and we actually need more
training and we need more resources and
what you're going to do if you deplete
us now we're working more you know
everybody on swat we're working more
hours we're understaffed it's like you
think that's going to help judgement
jamie would you do your buddy's job for
70 000 a year would i what would you do
his job the law enforcement the man on
the swat team at this point if i could
train and if i could do it yeah but
that's because i'm becoming a psychopath
i was like i would do it in a heartbeat
but but but a lot of people on the left
would not if that's what you were going
through i just think people people are
leaving the industry people are leaving
the profession because just the the
criticism and all the the anti-police
rhetoric out there and then you're going
to lose weight i'll tell you it's
dangerous when you look at some of the
cities now look at the homicide rates
the crimes going up through the roof why
would you keep down with that uh defund
the police and all that and this that
and you won't have police protection
well i tweeted this about yvaldi i said
this is what happens when you defund the
police and then everyone was like they
were well-funded you're wrong and it's
just like you need to understand the
subtlety here when the police are
demoralized demonized and attacked
relentlessly they're going to be like
i'm out no don't care i i do want to add
though
i'm a little salty on cops considering
what happened with covid because too
many cops for one i'll say a few things
cops enforcing unconstitutional gun laws
i think is a problem and during covid
cops enforcing unconstitutional edict
was a huge problem and the one thing
that was a big wake-up call for
conservatives and why a lot of trump
supporters and conservatives soured on
support for cops was because we saw cafe
owners salon owners while the downtown
gym owners yep yeah gym owners uh
attila's jim when you had this the
democrats releasing prisoners and
inmates who commit violent crimes and
then taking business owners and putting
them back in
people got really pissed off about that
but but it in the i tell you where did
you see that though you said you saw
that in these large municipalities where
there are police departments that work
for a chief of police who works for the
mayor and the city council so you didn't
see that with sheriffs you saw the
sheriffs they they're elected they the
only people wait
there could be some far left sheriffs
out there that would be doing that too
but a majority of the sheriff says i'm
not i'm not enforcing that i wasn't
going to enforce mass mandates because i
only answered to the people that elect
me chiefs of police have to answer to
mayors and the mayor is going to tell
the chief you get your people to do it
if you want to keep your job you're
going to do exactly what the heck i tell
you to do that makes it a little bit
more difficult as it relates to
municipal police departments and
sheriff's offices and who they're bosses
and but that's a thing a big distinction
there was one instance where a sheriff
in minnesota went and arrested a cafe
owner for opening her cafe but uh again
i'm not going to point to one case and
be like all the cops but a lot of people
were just like if this is what the
cities are doing so my attitude is kind
of like let the let the if new york want
to abolish the cops let them do it i
don't live there let the people see and
you see how it's going but i do kind of
think maybe an easy solution is cops
should be elected
like you shouldn't have a chief of
police appointed by a political
individual who then has his job held
over him we should vote for who the the
the police chief is
well they don't survive very long uh
chiefs of police their tenure as chief
is because the new mayor comes in he
wants to bring in his own pe you know
his own buddy well there's always a cop
that they have to deal with who doesn't
play by the rules and he's going to
retire soon and then they get into it
i was hoping someone picked up on that
i was really proud of it and as i was
saying it i was like oh it's dying this
is very but no i um
you said something earlier about how you
think most people actually do support
the police part of why i would agree
with that is because people as spineless
as joe biden during his state of the
union address we're willing to say
well we need the police to be well
funded which is what joe biden said
during his state of the union is no
don't defund them defend them like oh
interesting yes yeah um so this is
becoming a safe position in the polls
i'm sure it always has been but it's
something democrats are even willing to
say at this point well when when people
are watching violent crime skyrocket
some dude pushed him on the train tracks
in new york oh people don't want to live
there man yeah you know it's just and
it's not just in new york city it's all
the cities crime is through the roof and
they're moving to texas
you know we gained two congressional
seats new york last one california last
one we're hoping they're not bringing
that ideology
into texas i i think we should interview
them before we actually allow them
but they're moving into texas and you
look at you know we have constitutional
carry i mean we we have just texas is
one of the greatest states i'm proud to
be from it
um i i moved from la to austin and
everybody i met was like how are you
going to vote how are you going to vote
you're going to you're going to say if
you're going to come how are you going
to vote uh but then the worst thing i
saw was there's you know there's a
bumper sticker that says uh don't
california my texas and the first time i
saw it it was a dude with the florida
license plate and i'm like come on man
you're in the most liberal city in the
whole state oh i know travis county i
mean austin is very very very very
different it's all just wellness
podcasters it's terrible yes here it is
so here's the issue with texas you know
everybody was telling me like you guys
should move there you guys should move
there and i was just like no way
because elon musk he's cool right but
when he moves and and builds a factory
in austin and relocates his california
employees those people are progressive
they're liberals so it's not just about
joe rogan and ellen musk it's about
everyone they bring with them and then
when you know jamie you end up moving
there you got michael malus you get
these these prominent individuals
comedians and podcasters then the
periphery of those groups are going to
come as well and then california moved
to texas right people were like no it's
good that these people are moving
because they're they're they're you know
helping texas and they're making it red
and i'm like
maybe
but what's going to happen is a
california conservative is a far left
texan yeah and they come in and they'll
they'll vote republican because they
don't like california leftism which is
coming texas and they'll make texas
moderate not republican sure
eventually i mean but but look at 2020
trump run texas by 600 thousand uh you
saw the congressional race we heard i
think is texas thirty four first time
ever in the history have we saw uh seen
a a a a female mexican born in mexico
become a member of congress so i think
many of the just the policies the
policies of the left with the border and
everything else people are i feel pretty
i think we're going to do very very well
in the state of texas here in november
it's going to be a bloodbath thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there